[Music]
Magnus you ready for this uh I've never
done this before so I wouldn't know
quick question aliens come to Earth they
challenge you to the chest you have you
have Humanity you have to win they give
you the white pieces what opening do you
play
um in in such a case I'd probably play
an opening like one night that's free or
or the English or some opening that like
that just to keep a lot of pieces on the
board and try to to outsmart them
eventually uh besides I mean if I make a
couple of quiet moves at the start I
will probably be able to tell whether
the aliens are any good at chess or or
not
I don't know if you were following the
action but Sabi and Wesley have been
knocked out did you follow the matches
there
yeah it's just me against the kids now
oh man I took that guy down with my Rook
I'm so badass and your dad is like
Magnus
remember where you come from that was
the worst Norwegian accent ever
um yeah I think for me
um I like all sorts of
of trivia basically okay what's the
capital of Myanmar
uh it's Rangoon very good no more
questions that's an easy one
Magnus just as you're about to give up
one chess Crown you've taken a new one
so my question is when are you gonna
stop
well I'm gonna stop when somebody stops
me
what did you feel when Iranian blundered
is Queen happy what do you do to impress
and surprise your opponents
well I mean it's just small small tweaks
and known ideas uh or chest wise chest
wise ah other one it's not like or
something the surprise their opponent
but as I was researching you what's odd
to me is like you're totally normal
person people think about Chess Geniuses
is hanging out in their basement and
obsessively like chewing on their own
skin and you know maybe bodies hidden
somewhere in the house well you know I'm
only 21 years old so give me some time
to develop the crazy you know
I mean people use drugs to both prepare
for and to do exams for instance
I assumed they could possibly help in
chess as well
if at some point
my level of Chess drops drastically I
might start
experimenting but for now I don't see
the meat
does this actually work
you tell me
I'm guessing
I know you're guessing just sometimes
your guesses are right that's the
problem
one thing is like to play just this way
but to watch this must be
we're so sorry
I'm a Paul Hanson from a Danish chess
magazine can you reveal a little bit
about who are your trainers or seconds
yeah it's funny you should mention that
you're from the Danish chess magazine
because I can reveal a big secret that
my chief trainer is actually Danish
um the opening Choice suggests that
perhaps also a German is involved on the
team
you may speculate as much as you want I
think that's half the fun of being a
journalist at the world championship
match yes thank you
you're gonna Translate
well I I just have one suggestion turn
your attention to the knuckleberry event
yeah and that's going to be a hell of a
lot more interesting
so I think I see somebody play like this
I don't know why on Earth they would
this one is named after the a part of
the anatomy of an animal
like the donkey scrotum
[Music]
cut
I'm very close actually of course the
SAS
the monkey's thumb the monkey's bum on
the broadcast thing we deal with poker
uh she just couldn't understand why you
were playing so long in the end game so
when did you understand that this was a
draw
so
I think the question for you you know
why are you playing so on so long when
did you understand it was a draw
I mean when did I understand it was a
draw
I understood it immediately
Agnes tomorrow you're moving on to play
the young noderbeck abdusator of a world
rapid Champion how excited do you get
for matches like that against players
who potential World Championship level
Talent so how excited do you get for
matchups like that
he's worst he was championed in 2021 and
I took it back in 2022.
[Laughter]
you're right I'm sorry and Michael she
you have quite a lot of chairs in your
room we noticed uh uh you're not gonna
sell it in them on eBay for your fans at
all or give them any away as prizes
no uh whenever I am on the rare
occasions that I I do streams I need the
chairs for the idiots in the back
[Laughter]
David
David there's a victory here mean
anything as far as London is concerned
well
um not for me but I think Fabi needs to
win the tournament to to get to London
being being the grand Chester final not
the world championship
[Applause]
[Music]
no you need you need to win the event
well I think the last few months I've
generally won tournaments in which
Magnus is playing in so
[Music]
I meant I didn't mean to to trash talk I
meant to just State something factual
the first sentence of your autobiography
be I'm not a genius and what would the
title of your autobiography be my name
is Carson chest genius I don't know
keeping that in mind I would say my
favorite player from the past is
probably myself like three four years
ago
thank you